capital expenditure we also spend money
on improving land and buildings in order
to continue delivering excellent cost
effective services for all our customers
capital expenditure is the money spent
on the purchase and improvement of
buildings vehicles equipment and
computer software it's called capital
expenditure as it results in assets
which the council and the community can
use for more than one year capital
expenditure does not directly affects
the council tax from 2010-11 our
expenditure on capital was 1.7 million
pound compared to with what we plan to
spend of 1.2 8 million pound some of the
projects not completed last year will be
rolled forward into this year the actual
overspend is due to projects that went
ahead with external funding after the
budgets were agreed the 1.75 million
pound which was spent on our land and
prophecy property assets was paid for by
capital receipts from the sale of
property grants and from revenue what is
the council worth at the end of each
financial year the council draws up a
balance sheet that shows how much our
land and buildings are worth what is
owed to others for example invoices that
were unpaid as at 31st of March and what
other o others owe us for example
businesses which our aides and residents
who o council tax and how much cash we
have therefore our net assets up to the
31st of March this year was the value of
land and property at 39 million pound
cash in bank and cash investments 5.4
million pound money owed to Rochford 2.7
million pound less money owed by
Rochford
4.1 million pound and therefore the
total nest assets is 43 million pound
therefore Rochford's net worth is 43
million pound this is represented by
unusable reserves of 37 million pound
and revenue reserves of 6 million pound
the unusable reserves and balances till
31st of March of this year our capital
grants and receipts 2.6 million pound
working balances point nine million
pound earmarked reserves 2.5 million
bound totalling six million pound
delivering value for money the council
plans make savings during the year of
750,000 pound we were delighted to
report savings of around nine hundred
thousand pound for 2010-11 compared to
four hundred and eighty-five thousand
pound in the previous year this has been
achieved by more efficient service and
better organization not by a lower
quality or reduction in services and
council staff working harder than ever
to ensure the council offers is
residents value for money the council is
determined to deliver high levels of
performance rochford has shown that
despite having one of the lowest
government grant funding levels it
continues to save money and reduce
spending we will continue to keep keep
close scrutiny over council money
financial performance the council is
among the best in the country when it
comes to collecting council tax the
revenues and benefits team collected
98.9 percent of the four to seven
thousand point six million pound council
tax jus last year which was 2010-11 we
also collected 96.8 percent of business
rates do last year collecting income in
the current economic climate is
challenging but staff offer as much
port and advise as possible to help
residents and businesses to pay their
bills the council's plans for 2011
onwards asset in the corporate plan
which is available at www k
out and about there are some farmers
markets coming up great wakering at
community center the old school high
street great wakering on saturday
october the 15th between 10am and 1 pn
contact number for this is 0 1 702 to
186 31 rochford farmers market at the wi
hall west street rochford that's on the
first saturday of the month until
december the third between nine-thirty
and 1230 you can contact the clerk to
rockford parish council on 0 1 702 540
722 or clark at Rochford parish council
dot dot dot uk' and there's a farmers
market at hullbridge in the community
center pools lane hullbridge every
fourth saturday of the month the contact
number for this is zero one seven zero
to 2 30 37 for ray Lee's market will
relocate to the high street from october
with stalls in the taxi rank the new
taxi pickup point for Wednesday's will
be in the lay-by at the clock the market
will operate from 8am to 2pm anyone
interested in having a store can contact
the town clerk by email rayleigh dot
town council at bt open world com or you
can call 012 6874 1880 and book now to
take a wander around the RSP bees
stunning wallasey Island project stroll
along the seawall with a wallasey birder
and project volunteers watch the
landscape change with the seasons and be
inspired by the sheer scale of the wild
coast on your doorstep the wonders take
place on October the 8 and 9 30 octobre
the 29th at eleven-thirty November the
11th at 11am and November the 26
at ten-thirty the wonders are free of
charge but you must book for more
details contact Hillary on 0 1 702 258
357 or hillary hunter at rspb org dot u
K and stanbridge Memorial Hall will soon
be available for hire during the day and
evenings for meetings groups and
functions the hall will be available for
anyone to hire subject to terms and
conditions for more information and
bookings contact the Clark to Stanbridge
Parish Council on 0 1 702 double 55 347
and the Christmas lights are on in
rayleigh High Street on Thursday
November the 24th for 15 to 6 30 p.m.
please note the High Street will be
closed to traffic from 145 to 730 p.m.
contact 0126 ate 741 double 80 and hawk
will common it's on Saturday December
the third from 430 p.m. you can contact
017 0220 double 710 and in rochford
market square on sunday december the 4th
12pm 25 30 p.m. stores are available for
the event at a cost of 25 pound per
pitch so contact louise chapel at FS
male net south in hospital public
meeting you can find out more about
what's happening at the hospital from
the chief executive as well as listen to
clinical presentations on subjects such
as arthritis and prostate cancer by
attending public meetings taking place
near you the next presentation is on
Thursday October the 13th from 7 to 8 45
p.m. it will be held at Cupid's country
club Cupid's chase in great wakering
these meetings are intended to inform
the public about the hospital's
activities everyone is welcome including
children if you are planning on going
please let them know in advance by
calling the free phone number Oh 800 oh
1 8520 to or email foundation dot
members at southend dot NHS UK
complimentary tea coffee and biscuits
are available on arrival the Roche art
group meet on Wednesday evenings between
7 30 and 9 30 p.m. at some theresa's
church hall ashington road rochford
beginners are especially welcome but all
abilities are catered for at this
friendly club who work in a variety of
media at a venue with good lighting and
facilities the group is also set to hold
its annual exhibition on Saturday
October the 22nd
akcent Teresa's and admission is free so
for more details contact 0170 2207 568
please note that although events are
checked before going to publication they
are subject to change and we recommend
you visit our website at www k or
contact the organizers to check before
going to an event
community forums have been set up by the
council to give members of the public
and opportunity to ask questions
directly of their elected
representatives and representatives of
partner agencies where possible
questions will be answered at the
meeting all issues raised will get a
full response and questions and answers
will be posted on the council's website
there will be four regular community
forum meetings held each year to for the
east of the district held at the
rockford hospital site in Rockford and
two for the west of the district hell
held at the Civic suite in rayleigh each
forum will be chaired by the leader of
the council and will have senior
representatives from the county district
and parish town councils as well as from
the police the health service fire
service local businesses and other
agencies the theme of the first meeting
of the east and west forums will be
community spending although any local
issues can be raised forums are
scheduled for the rest of the year as
follows the east community forum their
meetings start at seven o'clock the
first one is on Tuesday the eighteenth
of October this year and the next one
after that will be tuesday the 20th of
march next year 2012 they'll be held at
the hawthorne center rockford hospital
in rockford the west community forum
their meeting start at seven thirty p.m.
the first one will be on tuesday the
eighth of november this year with their
second one on tuesday the thirteenth of
marked next year 2012 these meetings
will be held at the cilix wheaton really
if you'd like more information call 0170
2318 140 or email member services at
Rochford gov UK
when you contact the council you can now
leave us feedback on what you think of
our service the Gulf metric system gives
you a quick way of leaving feedback
whenever you contact the organization on
the phone by email on the web or in
person using the feedback service is
simple all you have to do is pick the
smiley face that best matches how you
feel about the service you received be
it happy neutral or unhappy you can do
this in the council offices using the
new touch screen in reception by
clicking the faces at the bottom of an
email or on the website by clicking one
of the buttons that is at the bottom of
every page customers who ring the
council will have the option of giving
feedback at the end of their call all of
this feedback is regularly reviewed by
staff who then try to keep doing the
things that residents like and to
improve the things that they don't we
also regularly update the website with
the results from feedback so you can see
how we're doing
and here are the council committee dates
and the first is the East community
forum to be held on the 18th of October
at the lecture theatre hawthorne center
rochford hospital Union Lane Rochford SS
for one RB and all the following
meetings will be held at the Civic sweet
hotly road rail e SS 68 eb and the first
is the standards on the sixth of october
the review on the eleventh of october
executive the 19th of october
Development Committee on the twentieth
of October a council meeting on the
second of November west community forum
the eighth of November executive on the
ninth of November the review committee
on the fifteenth of November development
the 24th of November the review
committee on the sixth of December
executive on the seventh of December
council meeting on the thirteenth of
December and all these meetings start at
seven thirty p.m. if you want any more
information please contact the Member
Services on 0 1 702 318 140